dix huit semaines assez glacial avec des
températures j'ai 27 ans je suis pigiste
en bois météomédia travailler ici pour
l'arrêter la boom fm je coache
candidates de miss québec ça j'adore ça
plus miss canada
ça fait 18 ans cette année que j'ai pas
dis papa pour même pas savoir comment ce
petit moulin peut manquer
c'est vraiment bon bah je n'aurais pas
pu espérer mieux chaque soir connectant
devenir no border guard et ça démontre
un quart d'heure à huawei à la famille
stand où le premier cyclone en piscine
avait par contre à minuit
la son mariage j'ai lancé mon grand père
était vraiment toujours m est très
partant très souriant
comme les ventes c'est un pas que
quelqu'un ait pu mourir et pas que la
guerre dans le monde ne veut jeter sur
un joli go je pense à la prochaine
collation vous allez dans ma vie dans ma
tête tout était beau après le souper au
parma diaries va prendre tomber je me
rappelle est dans le bain puis
d'entendre un cri le sellin raymond
lemay que de toute ma vie je pourrai
jamais entendre un tel cri ça peut être
évident pour ma mère d'annoncer à sa
petite-fille de l'avenue sa grande fille
de 13 ans que leur part se suicider je
tends ma mort de survie quand c'est
arrivé j'ai peu pleuré parce que je ne
voudrais pas le droit et faire carnet
une eau moins garde le sang froid
déjà que ma mère avait de la peine je me
dis si en plus on doit commencer à voir
une console et on y fait que j'ai 9 ans
et j'ai perdu mon père il s'appelle
raymond je m'ennuie de lui je l'aimais
et je l'aimé encore
même s'il est plus là les morts le 15
décembre
j'ai vu qu'on peut s'y faire abandonner
comme ça que je me suis toujours dit
c'est moi qui va partir en premier puis
vous me ferez pas mal du fait de la
difficulté avec pour l'amitié
je suis lâché loyal mais mettons en
amour ou tout ça j'ai eu de la
difficulté à m'abandonner j'ai eu un
homme à ma vie qui est extrêmement
important que j'ai vu qu'on pouvait
vraiment avoir des sentiments pour
quelqu'un j'ai commencé à voir comment
la mère a dû sentir la première soirée
que c'est accouché seule dans son lit en
sachant que son mari après 18 ans de
mariage allez pour revenir
aussi bizarre car quand les doigts là
mais il faudrait que le riz mais en même
temps j'en ai toujours parlé avec m
comme si je raconte un film d'ari qu'un
sentiment tellement détaché comme ont
été enlevés sur ce sommet bonsoir on dit
souvent qu'on ne devrait pas avoir
enterré à nos enfants mais je pense
qu'un jeune enfant devrait pas avoir
intéressé par an la réaction souvent si
je la comprends pas encore à ce jour
c'est un voyons dans qu'on dit ça ça
paraît tellement potes et elle m'en
souviens quand tu pourrais jamais
concevoir cette éviction dans ta vie
j'aimerais un peu qu'on en parle
petit copain qui veut pas de vainqueur
mais je pense que justement plus on va
en parler
west ham a trouvé j'en ai parlé avec toi
de façon de souligner avec toi un peu
donc ça n'est jamais par les facs de
vista comme ça au grand âge on the move
à amman il faut que ça vienne la
personne hostile
donc voilà ce sommet oui j'ai toujours
été là quand tu travailles tu as encore
ce dynamique encore à ce jour jeudi
raymond et elles font vivre et man et
simple qui est raymond raymond pour le
commun des mortels n'existe pas je les
pose ainsi à mon père que je me suis
juré que là ce moment là les gens autour
de moi que j'aime mes amis je le redis
je t'aime j'ai ce besoin là au boulot et
les gens avec qui j'aime travailler sont
au courant j'aime toucher je veux que
les gens autour de moi sache que sont
importants
il ya peut-être deux mois sur la route
comme c'est un café j'ai un flash motivé
appelé la fondation la prévention du
suicide en leur disant je vais faire une
vidéo je veux juste dites moi ce que je
peux faire pour vous aider
je vais le faire ce qui est vraiment fou
mais je crois en mon nom à la ville
était livrée aux arrangements puis on
devait avoir un rendez vous ils m'ont
annulée puis m'ont rappelé johannes
vient le 15 décembre où je dois qui ne
peut problème sans trop réfléchir et le
15 décembre je m'en vais à québec j'ai
un flash sur l'autouroute j'ai fait dix
huit ans joueront sûrement pas rumeurs
quand je veux faire marcher avec sa
fille
5 par an
à voir devant moi je sais pas ce que je
lui dirai je t'aime c'est sûr je te
pardonne je pense
je sais que les gens qui peuvent être un
peu froid s'installe sur la société ou
le pardon c'est dans leur foi dont
pardonner mais pas que ce soit je me
surprends j'étais allé dans une
direction que je pensais pas aller je me
souvenais même pas après avoir fait la
vidéo d' avance sur le rectangle j'ai
fait ok je le dis si je dis ce que je
laisserai je sais qu'un jour dans ma
ville je veux je vais craquer j'ai hâte
c'est sympa j'ai tellement il ya un mot
tant qu'il est là depuis des années
j'ai tellement hâte de la journée où est
ce que je vais pleurer s'il faut pendant
trois heures le puits de dormir comme un
bébé après mais quelques le laisser
sortir ça il est trois personnes par
jour qui s'enlève la vie au québec ça
aucun sens
que ce soit pour toi ou pour un proche
appel
si ça peut amener deux trois familles à
travers le québec a jasé novès
clarisse